yeah I think that my dear the dear
brother Barack Obama President Obama
he's a very complicated enough he has a
sterling Democratic rhetoric at his best
that reminds you of Saul Alinsky and the
others at times he has a technocratic
team when it comes to policy so there's
not just attention but oftentimes
there's contradictions between the two
you see he comes out of a black
tradition
we listen about telling the truth about
white supremacy but he himself holds
race at arm's length and tell there's a
crisis
Jeremih right here let's get changed
there you see and it's partly because
he's such a masterful politician he's
brilliant he's charismatic he's a master
a politician and he's concerned about
cutting the deal and winning the
election and I think in the end this is
going to be a major challenge for him he
has to decide whether he wants to be an
Abe Lincoln who began as a mediocre
politician Lincoln supported the first
proposed 13th amendment that said
slavery forever in the US Constitution
Frederick Douglas bought a ticket to go
to Haiti said I'll never live in a
nation that has an honorable amendment
Lincoln supported that that was
opportunistic at the core he ate it
slavery but he was willing to say keep
these people his slave I able to
preserve the Union see that's not the
Lincoln that we talk about is great
Lincoln became great because of Harriet
Beecher Stowe window Phillips Charles
something who was beat up by Preston
Brooks from South Carolina Frederick
Douglass Sojourner Truth Harriet Tubman
it was an abolitionist movement that
helped make Lincoln great Barack Obama
the choice between the greatness of a
Lincoln and the masterful mark of alien
sensibilities that would be Oh Clinton
who was brilliant charismatic masterful
but tended to be too opportunistic so
far Barack Obama had leaned more toward
the Clinton side than the Lincoln side
that was partly because he doesn't have
an abolition
the equivalent he doesn't have a social
movement that's what we need to do we
need to put pressure on him
that's a very good question I think the
kind of thing you're doing here on the
Internet is very important because it
won't take the old traditional forms of
just hitting the streets hitting the
streets will be one form it's got to
take a whole host of different forms
different voices different views
different visions put forward critiques
of what's going on behind the scenes to
reveal the contradictions of the Obama
administration we need young people who
are looking at the world through a very
different set of lens and even myself
because I'm old school you know no
school has a monopoly on truth that yes
I do still see classes and I see empires
and so forth and so on but there's also
ways of looking at the world through
popular culture that young people have
that I don't fully understand so that
some of their criticism would take form
that it would take me time to understand
and grasp but we have to have the
courage did not just raise our voices
but connect them to organizations so
that people can begin to see there are
alternatives then the old neoliberalism
dressed up in fashionable form with a
democratic rhetoric that hides a
concealed technocratic policy and it
could be that you know brocco Obama
himself you know he's waiting to make
his turn toward Lincoln that's greatness
he hasn't made it yet and of course the
decision on Afghanistan it's gonna be
very important it's gonna be difficult
to have a Peace Prize to be a war
president